das ist so dass die Ukraine mit
kleineren Einheiten und mit der
taktischen Ebene besser zurechtkommt als
mit größeren Einheiten und einer
strategischen Ebene und man merkt das ab
der Ebene der Brigade die Visionen hat
die Ukraine irgendwann mal abgeschafft
das ist schwer fällt die
unterschiedlichen Einheiten zu
koordinieren und gemeinsam zur Wirkung
zu bringen die Ukraine ist aber jetzt in
einem Gefecht dass möglicherweise zu
diesem Zeitpunkt solche größeren
Angriffe auch gar nicht möglich macht
weil ohne Luft Überlegenheit in
Minenfeldern in ausgedehnten flachen
Land man sonst mit diesen großen
Einheiten im Grunde auf dem
Präsentierteller stehen würde also muss
es zunächst einmal darum gehen die
Artillerie des Gegners zu dezimieren die
Logistik die führungs- und
Kommunikationseinrichtungen zu schwächen
und genau das sehen wir ja gerade mit
den Storm Shadow Angriffen auf die Krim
wo jeden Tag Munitionsdepots angegriffen
werden und mit dem gezielten Ausschalten
der Artillerie das zumindest bei
russischen Militär beobachten schon dazu
geführt hat dass sie gesagt haben dieses
dezimieren der russischen arzttergerät
durch die Ukraine das hat System das
schwächt die Russen und das wird am Ende
vielleicht zu einem Zusammenbruch der
russischen Front führen
hier ist eine Frage an Sie wenn die
Ukraine die f16-jets bekommt dann werden
sie ja auch Waffen dafür benötigen
werden dann höchstwahrscheinlich Raketen
mit größerer Reichweite geliefert
zunächst mal muss man glaube ich
festhalten die F16 kommen spät so wie
auch die Schützen und Kampfpanzer spät
kommen und leider haben die Partner der
Ukraine auch Deutschland noch immer
nicht erkannt wie dringlich die Dinge
sind und das zahlt nicht unendlich
vorhanden ist und es ist schon sehr sehr
frustrierend für die Ukraine die da im
Gefecht stehen dass die Prozesse bei uns
immer so ewig lange dauern hätte man die
Schützen und Kampfpanzer früher
entschieden dann hätte auch die Ukraine
mehr Zeit gehabt zum Beispiel das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen zu üben
das muss man bei dem Beurteilungen eben
mit einem fliegen fließen lassen bei den
F16 ist es so dass die sehr helfen
würden sowohl gegen die
Kampfhubschrauber und die russische
Luftwaffe als auch für die Unterstützung
der Truppen am Boden und dass die F16
natürlich bewaffnet werden müssen das
ist klar wird mich freuen wenn auch die
Bundeswehr dazu beiträgt oder die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland dazu beiträgt
mit den Taurus nachtflugkörpern die
Briten haben ja Sturm Shadow geliefert
die jetzt von ukrainischen Flugzeugen
aus abgefeuert werden
und die Franzosen skull beige und wenn
wir Taurus liefern könnten würde das
helfen ich glaube das ist technisch
machbar sein wird die zum Beispiel von
den F16 aus abzufeuern die Reichweiten
die damit erreicht Weichen werden können
reichen aus um das zu tun was die
Ukraine tun muss nämlich die Logistik
die Führung und Kommunikation der Russen
anzugreifen so dass dann die
Voraussetzungen da sind für Durchbrüche
und um die Creme unter Druck zu setzen
es geht ja gar nicht darum die Creme zum
Beispiel zu erobern sonst geht darum sie
unter Druck zu setzen sie vom Nachschub
abzuschneiden das halte ich für möglich
ich bin auch grundsätzlich weiter
optimistisch dass der Ukraine ein
Durchbruch gelingen wird an der Front es
geht nur eben viel langsamer als das
viele erwartet haben weil eben diese
Durchbrüche schnell nicht gelungen sind
und jetzt diese ganz akribische langsame
Vorgehensweise gewählt werden muss das
verstehe ich dass das viele frustriert
und dass man da schneller auf Ergebnisse
wartet aber die beste Handhabe die wir
haben ist auf langfristige Unterstützung
jetzt zu setzen systematisch und mit
Unterstützung der Industrie dann wird
der Ukraine glaube ich auch noch viel
gelingen
ein Punkt möchte ich gerne noch
rausgreifen nämlich die Kritik daran
dass das gelieferte Gerät nicht im
Verbund eingesetzt wird und dazu haben
wir die Kritik auch noch mal
zusammengefasst
manche Sicherheitsexperten erklären den
Verlauf der Offensive aus politischen
Gründen damit dass der Westen zu wenig
liefere aber das sind nicht immer
militäranalysten die Einsicht in die
Lage vor Ort haben deshalb möchte ich
die monokausale Erklärung nicht so
stehen lassen der Verlauf der Offensive
erklärt sich vor allem daraus dass das
gelieferte Gerät nicht im Verbund
eingesetzt wurde wo das einzelne System
seine Fähigkeiten am besten entfalten
kann das würde im Übrigen auch für die
geforderte Lieferung von Kampfflugzeugen
gelten ohne effektiven Kampf der
verbundenen Waffen würde auch das
Potenzial solcher Waffen nicht voll
ausgeschöpft werden können
also dass die Meinung von Herrn Gady
Birgit Unland schreibt auf Youtube die
Bundeswehr hätte mit dem mickrigen
Waffenarsenal der Ukraine doch keine
drei Monate eine 1.300 m Front Stand
gehalten also nicht meckern sondern
unterstützen ist der Kommentar von Frau
Unland die Frage des Einsatzes von
Geräten im Verbund hat der Experte da
recht
oder von Geräten von Sie wissen was ich
meine
ja er hat recht also die die Ukraine ist
nicht in der Lage das Gefecht der
verbundenen Waffen so zu führen wie es
das Maximum aus den einzelnen
Waffensystemen herausholen könnte die
Ukraine hatte schlicht und einfach keine
Zeit das zu üben und zu trainieren und
auch dafür viel Übung man braucht dafür
viel Kommunikation man braucht Erfahrung
und im Idealfall auch Einheiten die
schon lange zusammen sind wo das gleiche
Personal über längere Zeiträume diese
Dinge übt und dann auch miteinander in
den Einsatz geht aber diese
Voraussetzungen waren in der Ukraine
eben nicht da weil wir spät geliefert
haben weil die Ukraine Verluste erleiden
weil die Einheiten nicht so zusammen
bleiben insofern ist es finde ich ein
bisschen auch eine Diskussion zwischen
Theorie und Praxis und die Praxis dieses
Krieges ist eben nicht so wie sie am
reichsbrett oder auf dem Übungsplatz
wünschenswert wäre die Ukraine müssen
damit zurechtkommen und wir müssen
überlegen wie wir unter diesen realen
Bedingungen die Ukrainer weiter
unterstützen selbst wenn Ihnen das
Gefecht der verbundenen Waffen nicht so
gelingt wie es vielleicht wünschenswert
wäre das werden die jetzt während des
Krieges während der laufenden Offensive
nicht üben können oder nur beschränkt
verbessern können aber trotzdem wird die
Ukraine ja die ganze Zeit an sich
arbeiten um bessere Erfolge zu erzielen
man muss ja am besten aufpassen dass man
nicht so ein bisschen so ein
überheblichen Sound bekommt wo man so
den Eindruck erweckt die Ukraine
sozusagen würden mit Absicht schlecht
kämpfen oder mit Absicht die Hinweise
oder die Beratung der Partner ignorieren
wenn man andere Streitkräfte in dem Fall
die ukrainischen Streitkräfte berät muss
man glaube ich auch ganz nüchtern damit
leben dass die diese Ratschläge entweder
beachten oder teilweise beachten oder
dass sie eben das tun was wir für
richtig halten da sollte man nicht
beleidigt sein wenn die nicht das machen
was man für richtig hält
jetzt ist es natürlich
Interpretationssache ob die Bundeswehr
beleidigt ist oder nicht was wir wissen
ist dass es dieses interne Papier gibt
in dem man erstmal feststellt wie es
läuft und welche Schlüsse man daraus
zieht das wird man sehen aber dann
lassen wir uns doch hinten raus
versuchen irgendwie konstruktiv zu
werden wenn man feststellt ist läuft
nicht so gut wie es laufen sollte das
stellen die Ukrainer sehr sehr
schmerzhaft fest denn Sie bezahlen jeden
dieser Fehler mit Blut und das Stellen
andere Armeen fest die versuchen die
Ukraine zu unterstützen wie kann die
Zusammenarbeit denn konkret besser
werden
das dringendste ist die Frage wie kann
man mit diesen gemanagten Minenfeldern
umgehen kann man mehr Gerätschaften
liefern um Minen zu sprengen Minen zu
zerstören gibt es vielleicht auch neue
Ideen wie man mit diesen Minenfeldern
umgehen kann das ist ein ganz großes
Problem das ja alles andere auffällt und
das Gefecht der verbundenen macht und
kann man ja nicht gegen einen Minenfeld
führen sondern gegen den Gegner aber
dafür muss man dann den Gegner überhaupt
erst mal herankommen und dafür müssen
die Minen weg also das scheint mir das
größte Problem zu sein wir haben ja auch
gesehen als die Ukraine die ersten
Vorstöße versucht haben dass sie im
Grunde wie auf dem präsentiert werden
Teller in diesem Minenfeldern steckten
und dann von den Kampfhubschraubern
bekämpft wurden also da neue Rezepte zu
finden mehr Equipment zu liefern das ist
glaube ich ein wichtiger nächster
Schritt und dann andere nächster Schritt
ist die Russen werden besser im Einsatz
von Drohnen es gibt überall Drohnen an
dieser Frontlinie und den Ukraine
Instrumen Inseln in die Hand zu geben um
drinnen Abwehr entweder mit
elektromagnetischen Waffen oder mit
kinetischen Waffen durchzuführen das
scheint mir im Moment ganz wichtig zu
sein weil wenn man nicht sich bewegen
kann ohne dass man gesehen wird wenn man
permanent beobachtet wird von den
russischen Drohnen und viele der Drohnen
sind auch bewaffnet wenn man da ständig
bedroht wird dann ist es noch
schwieriger Dinge zu entfalten und zu
einem vernünftigen Aufbau des eigenen
Gefecht zu kommen also ich glaube da
gibt es einiges was man tun kann Minen
und Drohnen scheinen mir besonders
wichtig und dann ist doch klar Nachschub
beim Munition die industrielle
Unterstützung insbesondere bei
Artillerie Munition die ist noch nicht
so wie sie sein müsste da muss der
Westen dringend die
Produktionskapazitäten erhöhen damit man
Munition produziert und direkt in die
Ukraine bringt also das sind schon mal
drei Dinge die man jetzt tun kann alles
besser als zuzuschauen und das zu tun
was der ukrainische Oberbefehlshaber
saluschni ja zurecht kritisiert hat so
zu tun als sei das jetzt etwas wo wir
nur zu gucken wir haben Interesse daran
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt
und deswegen müssen wir immer überlegen
was wir auch tun können
letzte Frage an sie hat lange wie
schätzen sie denn aktuell die Offensive
der Ukraine ein
die Fortschritte sind gering vor allen
Dingen im Vergleich zu den Erwartungen
die ersten Schritte mit erwarteten
schnellen Durchbrüchen sind nicht
gelungen das muss man festhalten es gibt
viele Schwierigkeiten und wir haben über
einige gesprochen und dennoch sind die
Fortschritte ja jetzt stetig auch wenn
Sie mit diesem kleinen Einheiten
erreicht werden und ich glaube die
Dezimierung der Artillerie und der
Einsatz gegen Logistik und gegen
führungskommunikationseinrichtungen der
russischen Seite ist ein
vielversprechender weg ich halte es für
sehr wahrscheinlich dass der Ukraine
Durchbrüche gelingen werden die Frage
ist wie viele Reserven die Ukraine noch
hat in dem Moment wo ein Durchbruch
gelingt um den Durchbruch dann zu nutzen
und Gebiete zu befreien
die beste Unterstützung die wir leisten
können ist uns auf langfristige
systematische Unterstützung einzustellen
das wird der Ukraine eine Grundlage
geben da weiter voranzugehen trotz aller
Probleme bleibe ich optimistisch
das ist ein gutes Schlusswort vielen
Dank Nico lange dass Sie wieder bei uns
im Stream waren und ähm auch an euch und
Sie liebe Userinnen und User danke schön
lange